تقدم منصه حاضرين العديد من الخدمات
والمعلومات الارشاديه لمشجعي كاس العالم
القادمين عبر السعوديه وذلك بشراكه بين
عده وزارات وهيئه حكوميه لتقديم تجربه
ثريه وممتعه للمشجعين والزوار الراغبين
باكتشاف معالم السعوديه السياحيه سمير عبد
الرحمن العصيمي مع التفاصيل
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
حاضرين منصه جديده اطلقتها السعوديه قبيلا
انطلاق كاس العالم لنتعرف على ملامح هذه
المنصه
[موسيقى]
ما هي الجهات الحكوميه المشاركه في هذه
المنصه الهيئه السعوديه للسياحه بالاضافه
الى وزارات الرياضه والداخليه والاعلام
الى جانب وزاره النقل والخدمات اللوجستيه
وايضا تشارك الهيئه العامه للنقل وهيئه
الزكاه والضريبه والجمارك هيئه الطيران
المدني هي الاخرى تشارك في هذه المنصه
برفقه شركه مطارات القادمه
[موسيقى]
الى ماذا تهدف هذه المنصه على راسي
اولوياتها تيسير وتسهيل تجربه المواطن
والمقيم والزائر الراغبين بحضور مباريات
كاس العالم والعوده الى السعوديه حاضرين
تهدف الى توفير المعلومات الارشاديه
وايضا الخدمات لضمان تقديم تجربه ثريه
وسلسه وممتعه بجماهير كاس العالم
المنصات تهدف الى التعريف بمعالم السعوديه
السياحيه ووجهاتها المتنوعه للراغبين
بزياره البلاد خلال كاس العالم
[موسيقى]
مطارات الملك عبد العزيز الدولي في جده
والملك خالد الدولي في الرياض ومطار الملك
فهد الدولي في الدمام الذي نحن فيه الان
ستكون على اهبه الاستعداد لاستقبال مشجعين
كاس العالم وذلك عبر عده اجراءات وتسهيلات
ودعم اللوجستي للمسافرين عبر توفير رحلات
لنقل المشجعين بالطائرات يوميا هذه
الرحلات اليوميه التردديه تصلوا الى مطار
الدوحه الدولي خدمه النقل الترددي
بالحافلات الى هذه المطارات متوفره مجانا
مواقف السيارات حاضره في مواقع خدمات
النقل في الحافلات احضر شنطتك الصغيره
واستمتع بحضور مباريات كاس العالم
في حاله وجود اي استفسارات او حاله طارئه
فقط عليك زياره موقع هير فور يو دوت اس اي
او التواصل مع المركز الوطني للعمليات
الامنيه عبر الرقم
911 عبد الرحمن العصيمي من المنطقه
الشرقيه العربيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]